One more.
Daniel,
shall I like this question?
How would you give a speech to soldiers
entering the army about responsibility?
I will command and basic training unit
and address young soldiers advice.
Daniel,
what I would do is you
can take about this,
you could ask them to complete
the future authoring program.
I think that would be a really good idea.
But if you don't want to do that,
but you should ask them to like get them
to sit down for 90 minutes or an hour
even.
I would use the future authoring
program cause it's just easier.
But ask them what sort of soldiers
they want to be in three to five years.
Like if they could put themselves together
and be the best military and serve
the purpose that they enrolled in the
military for in the best possible manner,
what would they look like
as their own future ideal?
They have to think it through.
So,
and then the other thing you can ask them,
and this is also part of the
future authoring program,
is like what would your life look like
three to five years down the road?
If you fail in your,
in your desire to,
to become a proper soldier,
what sort of hell are you cording by
failing to take on the responsibility.
And if you can get them
to think that through,
you know,
the probability that
they'll do a good job,
we'll fastly increase,
really vastly increase.
Lots of young people have never thought
about who it is that they could be if
they started to be the
person they could be.
And so getting them to think about that
and write about it would be extremely
important.
So what I would do first of all is get
them to do the writing and the thinking
and then give the speech.
And maybe once they've done it,
you know,
you could ask them if they'd be willing
to share with you some of what they've
written.
I wouldn't make that mandatory because
then they might not be able to write
about it honestly.
So that's how I would go about it.